(lively music)
- Everyone needs a little pick-me-up.
A pat on the back or the old high five.
And here's a little dose
of, "You can do it," energy
from someone we love.
- I believe it all starts
with you and I in the mirror.
I don't know how to make
collective change out there.
I don't know what the policy is
to help the world get along better.
But I do truly believe
that if each one of us look in the mirror
and say, "You know what?
I'm gonna be a little bit better today.
I'm gonna be a little bit more fair today.
I'm gonna take a little bit
more responsibility today
to therefore get to my freedom tomorrow."
If enough of us do that,
that's how we make a collective change.
That's the soldiers that
I think we can all be,
going forward, so we can
have a little evolution.
Have fun doing it, too.
Break a sweat.
- Now that was inspiring.